I want you to create a budget a monthly
budget I want you to plan out exactly
what you're going to spend in every
category of your budget and this is
everything from food to electricity and
you are going to you're going to take
your lifestyle all the way down to just
needs so this is food shelter utilities
transportation and that's it survival
anything else and it's going to go
towards the smallest debt and you're
going to pay it off you're out and then
you're going to go and get two two extra
jobs you're going to work extra jobs on
the weekends you're gonna work extra
jobs at night and you're going to be so
focused and so intense at attacking the
stat and the great thing is if you focus
your money and you cut your lifestyle
and you have this intense moment you can
start to pay this off